ok welcome see Barbie are 12 okay two
games only i thought i would have played
him more often but ok yeah I tried the
French and 92
yeah I'm just thinking I mean I really
don't have a repertoire yeah it's in the
French but I was just thinking what what
can i play coming up with that one this
is the line that I have played when I
when I was still employing the French
regularly I didn't even have a bad score
with it I mean yeah it wasn't great but
it also wasn't entirely terrible black
gum tries to quite obviously they get
rid of his bad Bishop but or potentially
bad Bishop it's not always bad but it
loses time and well what this is I don't
know this doesn't really travel me that
much right my plane is playing this like
like it's the most normal way in the
world okay i want Bishop e7 without
Bishop g5 hitting so I went age six
first I mean I'm not saying I'm better
anything but does this cannot really be
the reason why be success considered to
be somewhat of the backwater of theory
and ma'am okay am so what what exactly
do I want to do I can maybe play c4 and
go for B 5 I don't know what is that
what what is it with my king hmm I
should have put it castling looks kind
of wrong maybe to see 7am just to see
seven okay not too quick if I do go
there he has see form okay my intention
was to play see for myself and then go
for a b5 later hmm
ok yeah I will see one is an interesting
move
if I go see 492 we will go for B 3
definitely and try to try to open up the
position my pieces are not well
positioned for this kind of opening of
the position especially later hmm maybe
I still have to do that it's not it's
not really great but whatever
hmm
uxie wanna remarkable muth played that
very very quickly and okay so I this is
why I when Drew gade the move King the
aid is not not really fitting into all
of that now but I didn't really
anticipate his play here what about
Bishop e3 this isn't Luke see to night
before one point he would go to be one
very likely but i'm not sure that i
gained much from that okay is he form i
have night before yeah but King looks
looks really really wrong here maybe
maybe I can play King c8b son this is
kind of this kind of business yeah his
first and foremost goal here is to just
play as quickly as possible without
directly blundering stuff he's so
successful up to now I mean this is
gvoice it's just helping me of course
but anyway okay so let's see what is he
doing now I think yes to go g5 otherwise
the pawn is gone or am i overlooking
something
maybe I could have played Ruth age three
but then we'll get three I don't know
after g5 I am hmm i don't know if i
should really do that it's an
interesting question 97 f 5 is coming
with the tempo yeah it just gives me the
rock right or is there a problem with
that that was a that was already in the
position anyway one move earlier ok so
checking here first it takes a five
probably Bishop before is good we should
be for this is right I guess
ya know it starts to use time that's
fairly typical blitzing out everything
and don't really I don't know never
never got to get this concept why you
want to screw up the whole thing with
those blitz blitzing moves and then
start of think when you're already
completely busted you can already only
hope for time win but okay let's see
alright still still some some tricks in
this position okay do I want to take
here I can also give this chicken I'm 32
okay let's let's take this first check
came and look at you two now form for
the doubling on am i overlooking a maid
or something I should chat try to try to
be quick
check-check
you
40 seconds Jim that I get the apron I
get it white resides mmhmm yeah he
played it very very interestingly here I
mean here I think should be about equal
probably i don't really think that
someone can claim something here I'm
definitely okay but nothing particularly
great look see one has a funny move here
am I interesting very interesting I
didn't really I made a mistake him I
don't think that this is a bad move but
I made a mistake in not even considering
the capture actually I was some I didn't
really think about the move at all
somehow I thought well he can take with
the night and the d4 square whatever but
I just take you five yes I mean this is
yeah it is a pawn right there is no
compensation I thought not be 50 but
it's not serious and if he has to take
with the poem which is the case then i
can actually play this and this and this
is quite nice it's actually a nice
position i have good chances to get in
b5 and do something on the queenside
yeah computer says slight edge for black
which probably is right very slight but
yeah I'm comfortable here probably
better than than this ok went with the
capture rook c8 yeah the idea is that if
we go see for now I have this idea and
when i get a night to d5 in this I mean
this kind of thing here I mean I'm in
really good shape so C 4 immediately
it's not a great idea okay I could have
played Bishop e3 here I mean I saw the
idea
but I mean this is this was was very
very clear but I wasn't sure that this
is so great a night a 7 ok I was only
seeing that this isn't this isn't so
clear can you take him for loop III ok
it was it was interesting went here
again Bishop a three-hour ok then I
didn't really see that I can go again
move the night that quickly ok g6 it's
not bad but I can't go Bishop e3 and TM
ya can't take stakes and now I finally
finally went for this move and he
stumbled you stumbled into this tactic
which was in the position for a couple
of moves already so yeah ok yes to go
here and then I wanted to play 97 now I
saw that this is a great square but I
can even go to f5 with the tempo and
yeah this is almost and I know that's a
very very tricky position for wine he's
definitely worse computers on minus one
so I don't really think that I mean I i
played this be six lines sometimes and I
always felt that white has this kind of
moves I think this is more dangerous
where the queen is coming out or you can
also put out the Queen immediately I
always felt that this is more dangerous
where the night might come like that and
there's pressure on the Kings side but I
don't know if if this is some this is
that gray in the fire yeah I actually
played quickly a computer wants to do
this with a good position now I get here
yeah maybe maybe that was better but
okay I wanted to play a little bit
quicker okay thanks for watching